and that was it
china's winter games are done
these were the olympics where team gb
were saved by the curlers
silver medal winner bruce mauit carried
the flag after the women's team had just
won gold
everhead at her fourth olympic games led
a comprehensive win over japan
i can't wait till tonight and then the
next few days to kind of just sit back
and and take a minute and realize what
what this team has done and then what
we've done for curling in great britain
but but also for ourselves as well
vicky wright on the team is a frontline
nurse who has worked on a covered ward
while training for beijing
this is their sports moment
and then hips up
back and forward with your left foot
and trust me it is harder than it looks
i think it's really special especially
coming back to scotland where curlin's
kind of started um it'll be really good
to welcome the teams home and just we're
all really proud of them
while curling clubs already have a
beijing bounce the other team gb medal
shots missed their targets and some of
them are very well funded
it is disappointing what we'll be doing
with all of the sports is reviewing what
we've done in this four year cycle what
we've done in the lead up and what took
place at the games and really getting
under the skin of actually why didn't we
achieve what we hoped that we would in
some of the sports
plans for a huge indoor snow slope in
murtha tidfield in south wales would
offer a facility bigger than anything
else in the uk
commitment to winter sports isn't
melting away just yet
but this time it was just the curlers
who are bringing back that precious
metal
tom parmenter sky news edinburgh